hello everybody and welcome to part 10
welcome to part 10 of amnesia the Dark
Descent ah so you write up the brain
sewers as a means of transport this bit
they were built to divert water from an
underground spring and are quite
spacious huh it seemed only natural to
incorporate it into the overall
structure of course but we won't use it
not today the flow is seasonal and when
that bring runs dry the damp tunnels
produce a rather poisonous type of fungi
there is an antidote of course but
they'll be bothering with it today
come this way instead we're almost there
uh-huh all right then ah finally thanks
of time
ah so ah all right sounds good
up out of oil more oil bath water I like
it
actually I don't because it reminds me a
bad shoot bad stuff man fired
Jimmy Alex King
that I'm scared of your honor
do i oh oh oh yep yeah haha ah so smart
uh man I must be a genius I'll take
everyone else like ten years to figure
that out
splat yeah ha yeah alright that's a
problem rock rock rock rock boom alright
that didn't work ma'am dude [ __ ]
Oh ah yeah hey you're Sam one more time
come on BAM
ha so smart
that's why you guys watch my videos
right cuz I'm so smart
yes pant Anson
huh ah there we go
right
I can go that way but I'll do this one
first ah control them that seems
important
all right where am I
who's out there
huh
who knows all right Wow
achtung the box if you burned you
yeah
right ah
ah
ah
Greece that too
ha-ah see Oh what I can't read this note
not good enough I'm not good enough
sure look I get it
collect these for something don't know
what
ah these can do oh I get it I get it
Miri hi
bam bam bam middle hi uh-huh I got it
I'm Jimmy's little ah
higher ah there we go
and oh yeah
oh I'm smart oh yeah booyah
oh yeah I'm a genius
oh yeah that's that's a good sign always
love it when there's a skull on the door
oh ah go through you can make it ah ah
maybe
what was the earth did I see something
or that's front flood there's no big
scoop
and now it's like
Amerigroup
probably
ah ah
shebang
was okay
Hey ah so something behind the stairs
nope la blah generations and men
limitations of this world build thing
100
tamed lightning crudely what is he
Frankenstein is that who this guy is Oh
thought of my monster this guy is
Frankenstein knew it yeah yeah yep yep
yep
no see down here oh there's always
things behind the stairs
I know these developers know this go
care about you going on here
oh I get it doctor mirrored it again
haha what's it this stairs nothing whole
lot of nothing
so mad bro these forceps this hammer my
axe
please
that do it up
aha easy I'm so smart I mean this is
really difficult and that's why my
smartness is able to calm down
what no don't say anything Daniel don't
answer him
yeah yeah
all right pipes pipes pipes ah pipes
I know I know pipes pipes
yeah
yeah
boom
probably yes once again mirroring that
makes it easy
Oh weird where does it go up boom does
pleasure that's where this one case
where Daniel actually does something
there haha
all done what's it done oh come on
Oh do we know listen oh alright
ah yeah genius
alright let's go do something
oh well is it that amazing
what do I do now
another way out
ah
hang on a second that was annoying me I
knew it had to be annoying you place is
way too loud
sit back in sit
another one
you're not a chess your fake chest
ah angry so mad ah
looking looking not finding was it under
the stairs no nothing's ever any stairs
in this game
well I guess this is where the game ends
cuz obviously I'm just going to die here
no hope for me
yep-yep sardis oh wait a minute oh I'm
stupid I got the freakin item a crank
haha dude hi Clark I get to take that
with me nope
okay well that was useful for something
that I suppose oh it's nice not to have
that many monsters I know it was
probably really bad karma to say that
right now but I don't care I'll do what
I want
haha I'm a genius I'm gonna go this way
first
what
what I spend all that time fixing you
and you break huh yeah I get you I'm
gonna get you mortgage yeah [ __ ] fine
this way you'd be conserving water from
the spring ah yes
it enables me to control the water and
rain sewers to some extent also it can
be used for all sorts of purposes not
one again here well they're tuned but
mostly to run different machines exactly
on so boned ah
so boned
okay far so good yeah
okay all right it's not so bad all right
haha 1839 there is no denying that
Alexander put a lot of faith into what I
can only describe as magic that's
because it is even while traveling
across Europe I assumed I would have to
embrace the supernatural to save my mind
and life well you do as a novice I do
everything in my power to stay focused
and not dwell too much on my own doubts
well look where that's got Santa woke me
up early and told me it was time we got
started on our work in your bed again
being only excited to get going and we
headed downstairs to the old dungeon
where he preferred to attempt his
rituals from the darkness
Alexander is a true renaissance man
paralleled only by DaVinci I'm sure oh
I'm sure showed me several rooms fitted
for specific research such as Anatomy
studies alchemy and botany what the
crown of brennenburg must be the inner
sanctum a most hallowed ground where we
shall attempt to permanently banish orbs
shadow yeah Alexander's gonna betray you
even I can see that
ah
oh he was so bright oh shut up
favorite dessert guy in there all am i
drowning him
haha it's okay ah
alright I'm totally calm and collected
now no water monster that's something I
guess
alright I got to take a pause right here
but I'm gonna go right back into the
action I just got to swap out the videos
thanks for watching [ __ ] why about
thanks for watching guys and prepare for
cart 11 goodbye